how much it is hurting us as a family of
people to educate their children a
social media video which has captured
attention across the globe
this is nine-year-old Caden moments
after he was picked up from school
pleading for an end to his life he says
he's been bullied because of his
dwarfism the video was posted on
Facebook by his mom who wanted to show
parents and teachers how much damage her
son's bullies had caused everything he's
going through with his medical condition
the suicide attempts are very real and
people don't understand that the video
which has been viewed over 14 million
times has gone viral and prompted an
outpouring of support from around the
world including this message from the
film star Hugh Jackman quite you were
stronger than you know mine and no
matter what you got a friend in me the
indigenous all-stars rugby team also
sent a heartfelt message to Kayden as
well as giving him the opportunity to
lead the team out this weekend Kayden is
the face of a campaign aimed to tackle
discrimination against wolf ISM before
this video was posted he had over 90,000
followers on Instagram he's been
described as an influencer and has
appeared in a number of TV documentaries
but despite being in the public eye his
mom says he's been on the receiving end
of relentless bullying speaking to Sky
News actor Warwick Davis had some advice
for Kayden believe in yourself you're a
much better person than they are okay so
be confident even if you have to fake it
at first be confident and they will
leave you alone it's not just celebrity
support Kayden is getting children in
different countries have posted messages
of friendship even a GoFundMe page has
exceeded a hundred and fifty thousand
pounds in donations
cadance mother wanted to reveal the
impact of bullying on her young son
she's now hoping her video which has
been seen by millions will put an end to
his torment Inzamam Rashid Sky News